et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Julien Robert bonjour Julien bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous députés
républicain de Vaucluse on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet bonjour Stéphane bonjour Stéphane
qui dirige le bureau parisien du journal
Ouest-France et on commence Julien
Lambert avec Jean Castex qui a donc reçu
hier soir les chefs de parti et les
présidents de groupes parlementaires
pour faire un point sur la crise
sanitaire et sur la méthode du
gouvernement est-ce que les républicains
soutiennent le gouvernement dans la
gestion de cette crise les républiciers
sont interloquées parce qu'ils sont
d'amis à base de la d'ailleurs exprimé
très clairement ils sont on est sortis
de la commune d'ailleurs tous les
présidents de groupe et de parties sont
sortis de là quand même sur leurs fins
par rapport aux questions qui se posent
donc je voulais nous en soutien dans le
sens où on a envie effectivement que
notre pays sorte rapidement de cette
crise sanitaire mais force est de
reconnaître que le gouvernement ne nous
y ait pas beaucoup pourquoi
parce qu'il y a pas de méthode
rappelez-vous qu'il a lancé sur les
masques qu'on nous expliquant ça servait
à rien puis maintenant on est passé à
une doctrine extrême ou si vous l'avez
pas aux toilettes quand vous êtes tout
seul vous commettez un grave crime on
est passé on est en aussi entre une
communication anxiogène ou on explique
aux gens qu'il y a une deuxième vague
c'est terrible et en même temps des
mesures qui ne sont pas toujours à la
hauteur ou on dit qu'en fait il faut
préserver le moteur économique et puis
derrière on a des affirmations martiales
du gouvernement parfois aussi la volonté
de cacher certaines insuffisances je
fais partie de la commission d'enquête
sur le covid et une logistique qui ne
suit pas et avec des gens qui n'assument
pas toujours leur responsabilité donc
moi je souhaite concentre rapidement de
cette crise je souhaite que ça se passe
bien pour l'économie mais en même temps
j'aimerais que chacun assume ses
responsabilités qu'on ne se retrange pas
des scientifiques qui ne sont pas
toujours d'accord entre eux et que au
plan de la logistique Jean Castex et le
gouvernement suive mais la stratégie
gouvernementale elle est plutôt facile à
comprendre à suivre tester tracer isolé
est-ce que le problème c'est justement
que elle est facile à comprendre marche
pas du tout mais il suffit pas
simplement de définir une stratégie il
faut s'en donner les moyens
par exemple le fait qu'ils soient
complètement engorgé qu'il faille 10
jours en région parisienne pour avoir
les résultats d'un test et CR de ce que
j'ai compris d'abord si vous voulez en
fixe des objectifs je suis pas certain
que on a fixé des objectifs totalement
partenariat avec ceux qui étaient
capables de faire ces tests de manière à
voir de manière calendaire je dirais la
montée en puissance donc à un moment
donné il y a une attente sociale c'est
normal puisqu'on était en retard et puis
ensuite vous avez un président qui dit
on va arriver à X centaines de milliers
de tests par semaine sans visiblement se
poser la question de la montée en charge
mais je vous rappelle quand même que en
juin il y avait un début de polémique
j'étais invité sur les plateaux on
disait mais alors on a plein de tests
qui ne servent à rien ça sert à rien
donc il faut si vous voulez modérer les
critiques parce que le gouvernement
essaie de faire ce qu'il peut reste que
quand même sur le sujet des tests comme
sur le sujet des masques il est il ne
peut être que plus responsable je dirais
de la logistique voilà et il y a je
crois un défaut d'organisation
logistique c'est pas seulement de
l'administration confond les deux il y a
un défaut d'organisation de logistique
de l'État qui s'est vu d'ailleurs
pendant la crise avec des collectivités
territoriales qui ont
occupé le champ libre avec du coup des
disparités criants entre territoire
entre ceux qui avaient les moyens de le
faire ce qui n'avaient pas les moyens de
le faire mais dans sa stratégie
j'encaisse qui donne justement la main
en territoire avec désormais des mesures
territorialisées vous qui parlez
beaucoup des territoires chez les
républicains vous dites bravo c'est la
bonne méthode
de passer par les territoires
le fameux couple primaire préfère oui
alors moi je suis très content que
effectivement on révalue le rôle du
préfet le rôle du maire encore
faudrait-il d'ailleurs qu'on en tire les
conséquences si un jour on fait un texte
soit décentralisation pour revoir et
considérer que c'est bien la maille de
la République qui se fait dans les
communes parce qu'on les a quand même
privé c'est pauvres maires de quasiment
toute leur prérogatives quant au préfet
on les a transformés 20 fois on
animateur départementaux donc on en tire
les conséquences on est peut-être aller
trop loin dans la manière dont on
concevait la décentralisation parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a aussi un autre
discours qui dit mais il faut aller vers
la différenciation vers une sorte
d'autonomisation et pourquoi pas de
fédéralisme et je le combat parce que je
crois que c'est pas l'essence de notre
pays donc oui très bien mais pas
il faut quand même voir moi j'ai des
mères qui m'ont dit le maire d'à côté
fait des gros annonces généralement le
maire d'une grande commune et puis moi
j'ai les gens qui me disent et vous
pourquoi est-ce que vous ne nous
apportez pas les masques j'ai un jour un
maire qui dit mais nous forcément si on
fait pas ça veut dire qu'on voulait
qu'on meurt en fait non non parce que
vous dites que je le fais pas en réalité
la raison est simple c'est que je n'ai
pas les moyens de le faire bon et vous
avez eu des régions très réactives la
mienne par exemple a été très réactive
Renaud mais je lui a fait beaucoup de
choses et puis d'autres vous avez des
régions qui ont moins existé mais tout
simplement parce qu'elle n'avait pas
forcément les moyens parce que la
coordination fonctionnait moins bien et
c'est ça qui me choque si vous voulez
alors après sur la stratégie tout à
l'heure qu'on a cité isolé tester c'est
la stratégie de la Corée bon c'est
exactement si vous voulez vous avez un
rapport qui a été fait d'ailleurs qui
est très important
donc à un moment donné c'est pas la
stratégie qui est en cause mais d'abord
le gouvernement beaucoup de temps pour
s'en rendre compte moi le 1er avril j'ai
sorti une tribune qui disait il faut
isoler les malades et il faut proposer
le masque pour tous dans la rue donc à
l'époque le gouvernement disait
l'inverse c'était le 1er avril il a
fallu six mois pour que le gouvernement
se mette d'accord là-dessus et en six
mois il y a eu un effort intellectuel
mais pas un effort je dirais sur la mise
en oeuvre concrète et visiblement nous
n'avons pas envoyé grand monde en Corée
pour aller voir comment ils avaient mis
en place ces éléments sur l'aspect
strassage par exemple l'application stop
covid manifestement ne fonctionne pas du
tout et n'a pas été adopté par les
Français qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
pour le vaccin on nous dit tout ce que
la clé de cette maladie ce sera la
vaccination est-ce que est-ce que vous
pensez que les gens se font vacciner vu
toutes les réactions anti vaccins qu'on
peut observer en France moi je crois si
vous voulez qu'à mon année on doit
respecter la liberté individuelle donc
vous seriez pas pour imposer le vaccin
par exemple pas pour qu'il soit
obligatoire je serai pour que on impose
le vaccin pour certaines catégories de
public exposées je pense que par exemple
pour certains professionnels par exemple
pour les professionnels de santé et
parce que je pense aussi que la personne
âgées
éventuellement oui parce que notamment
pour les professionnels de santé je
crois que il n'y a pas de mouvement
anti-vaccin bon mais nous sommes dans
des sociétés on peut pas fonctionner
comme sous le général de Gaulle on peut
pas dire aux gens maintenant c'est
l'armée vous allez tous passer au vaccin
les gens ont besoin de comprendre on le
voit sur Linky sur la 5G sur tout ce qui
touche à leur santé on peut faire mine
de ne pas le voir mais il faut mon nez
le prendre en compte alors il faut pas
tomber dans l'anti-centisme mais en même
temps il faut écouter aussi les gens qui
critiquent moi je suis pour la
vaccination maintenant j'ai aussi des
questions pourquoi certains vaccins qui
étaient administrés il y a certaines
années ont été interdites pourquoi
d'autres très chers ont été mis sur le
marché et qu'est-ce qu'on y met
exactement dedans parce que vous avez
des interrogations de légitimes de
citoyen mais vous êtes pour rendre le
vaccin obligatoire pour certaines
catégories d'épilations sur le plan de
relance Stéphane
alors moi j'ai une question sur le plan
de relance il est très impressionnant
100 milliards 100 milliards d'euros
c'est quand même une somme énorme je
crois que ça s'est pas fait dans ce pays
depuis des années on peut le dire par
contre la volonté de consommer cette
cette somme en deux ans est-ce que ça
vous paraît réaliste ou est-ce qu'il y a
une arnaque dans l'histoire alors
d'abord je pense qu'il y a une petite
arnaque sur le chiffre de 100 milliards
je me méfie toujours moi je me méfie
toujours si vous voulez des chiffres
ronds en politique quand les gens vous
disent on va créer 10000 emplois on va
dépenser 100 milliards parce que je sens
le communicant qui dit il faut frapper
l'esprit de l'opinion publique et donc
c'est un plan qui a été fait pour
quelque part donner confiance aux
Français nous le chiffre magique de 100
milliards quand vous rentrez dans le
détail des milliards qui viennent de
l'Union européenne il y a des milliards
qui sont redéployés en réalité l'efforts
réel et sans doute plus proche de 40 que
200 bon deuxièmement on est sur des
stratégies
d'investissement alors je donne par
exemple un exemple qui concerne mon
domaine plutôt d'expertise l'hydrogène
vous avez un grand plan hydrogène le
grand plan hydrogène c'est pas ça qui
demain va permettre de sauver votre
marchand de journaux je dirais menacé
c'est très important pour le secteur
mais c'est à plutôt horizon 2030 bon de
plus le grand plan hydrogène on a prévu
par exemple donc des moments de capacité
certains disent il faudrait de
l'électricité intermittente pour
permettre de faire cette hydrogène ça
n'a pas du tout été prévu dans les
capacités actuelles nous la
programmation plus rainure de l'énergie
donc si vous voulez si on veut faire ce
plan hydrogéné donc dépenser ces
milliards un moment donné on va buter
sur la cohérence avec ce qui avait été
prévu auparavant dans les projections
énergétiques et un exemple de
communication politique qui ne cadrera
avec une stratégie industrielle et donc
c'est à mon avis plus un plan je dirais
d'investissement sur le moyen terme et
le long terme que un plan de soutien
l'économie à court terme d'où d'ailleurs
votre
âme très intéressante question c'est qui
risque de pas être en fait consommer sur
deux ans tout simplement parce que il y
en a pas aujourd'hui besoin parce que il
suffit pas c'est exactement le même
problème que sur les masques il suffit
pas pour le pour le politique de dire ça
y est j'appuie le bouton et demain nous
sommes un grand pays l'hydrogène ça
marche plus comme ça et donc nous
n'avons plus les outils on manque
d'ingénieur de l'État si vous voulez si
on veut être capable de mettre en place
ces politiques il faut restaurer
Polytechnique comme grand corps de
formation d'ingénieurs il faut remettre
des ingénieurs dans l'état il faut
recréer une DGA qui soit une vraie
Direction générale de l'armement une
vraie DGA qui fasse qui soit une
incubateur de projets industriels et
remettre dans tous les ministères des
fonctions logistiques et ça ça prend pas
deux ans et là effectivement vous pouvez
commencer à dire je vais faire un plan
de relance mais clairement puisque vous
aurez à vous prononcer sur les mesures
de ce plan de relance dans quelques
semaines au Parlement qu'elle sera votre
position si c'est dans le projet de
budget puisque ils ont été malins ils
ont mis le plan de relance dans le plan
de budget annuel mais le budget
préliminaire il est si vous voulez pour
l'année 2021 moi je vais me prononcer
pas sur le plan de lance regardez ce que
effectivement on dépense du budget voilà
et donc ce sera un vote négatif parce
que le budget c'est un vote symbolique
c'est ce que vous êtes dans la majorité
ou dans l'opposition il faut pas être
ambigu il y a trop si vous voulez de je
dirais de de rumeurs qui laisseraient
croire que finalement les républicains
seraient à la République en marche que
le Coca Light est au coca mais moi je ne
suis pas du coca light donc je vote
contre je vote compte parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'autres raisons pour
lesquelles je m'y oppose et parce que il
y a des choix budgétaires qui n'ont pas
été fait pendant des années maintenant
ça commence un peu à être corrigé je
pense notamment au secteur de l'énergie
où ils sont en train de revoir tous les
prix sur le photovoltaïque etc mais
voilà pas d'opposition constructive nos
positions tout court oui mais vous savez
tout cela encore c'est la communication
je suis dans l'opposition constructive
alors vous avez des gens qui sont dans
l'opposition constructive et puis après
dans la majorité vous avez des gens qui
sont dans la majorité
alternative ou destructive tout ça à un
moment donné devient très compliqué moi
vous savez je suis un homme politique
basique voilà il y a les Gaulois il y a
les Romains je joue chez les Gaulois
c'est Emmanuel Macron qui va donc
annoncer le doublement du congé
paternité qui passera de 14 à 28 jours
avec une partie obligatoire est-ce que
vous soutenez cette mesure
ecoutez en tant que papa j'aurais été
très heureux d'avoir effectivement cette
période de congé paternité je suis pas
certain que j'aurais pu la prendre parce
que malheureusement mon année on peut
pas non plus s'absenter trop longtemps
donc à partir obligatoire pour faciliter
voilà écoutez si on peut se le payer je
crois qu'on a besoin de protéger le lien
familial et que quand une femme vient
d'avoir un enfant c'est très compliqué
de le gérer tout seul voilà et donc
c'est bien qui est le papa parce que les
premiers temps sont difficiles surtout
pour le premier enfant 500 millions
d'euros ça va coûter en année pleine
vous dites il faut les mettre sur la
table
une civilisation oui se démarque
lorsqu'elle sait faire des choix
budgétaires qui correspondent à des
choix de vie et qui les assument vous
déposez une proposition de loi visant je
cite à punir pénalement l'appropriation
du bien d'autrui sans motif légitime et
à défendre le droit de propriété en
clair c'est une proposition de loi
anti-squatteur quel est l'objectif
est-ce que vous dites qu'aujourd'hui la
justice n'est pas assez efficace en fait
on a un problème c'est que vous l'avez
vous avez le droit de propriété qui est
dans la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen et ensuite vous
n'avez aucun mécanisme de protection
dans le Code civil on ne protège que la
vie privée c'est en protège les
personnes on protège votre domicile d'où
tout un pan de je dirais de
jurisprudence qui est de dire je protège
le domicile donc l'intrusion dans le
domicile dans ce qu'on punit c'est la
personne qui rentre par effraction dans
votre domicile et d'où ensuite tous les
problèmes de squat quand quelqu'un au
bout d'un certain temps a fait de votre
propriété son domicile il est donc plus
protégé que le propriétaire ce que je
propose dans cette dans ce texte c'est
de protéger la propriété toute personne
qui vole votre propriété est puni
pénalement pas l'introduction le fait de
l'occuper à condition qu'elle ne puisse
pas montrer un bout de texte un bout de
papier qui se voilà pourquoi j'y suis et
donc vous avez un effet dissuasif vous
pouvez aller voir votre squatteur en
disant mais monsieur vous êtes ou madame
vous êtes chez moi et ça c'est puni de
tant d'années de prison et de milliers
d'euros d'amende et donc ça va faire
réfléchir les squatteurs parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils savent qu'ils ne
risquent finalement que les fractions il
n'est pas normal dans nos sociétés
modernes que si demain je vous pique
votre scooter je risque plus pénalement
que si je vous pique votre appartement
pendant trois ans cette proposition de
lent à l'Assemblée alors elle est
déposée pour l'instant n'est pas entré
dans une niche moi je souhaiterais dans
un esprit de concorde bi partisans que
la majorité en marche reconnaît ses
erreurs sa textes un peu moins élaboré
qui avait été déposé il y a un an il
avait rejeté sans même le discuter avec
un mode de motion Roger préalable je
souhaiterais qu'il le reprenne parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils veulent faire un
petit amendement qui ne va corriger en
fait que la partie administrative c'est
là la partie police la partie préférée
le préfet d'ailleurs qui aura la
possibilité de vous dire non je refuse
d'expulser les squators au bout de 48
heures et vous retournerez dans les
mêmes problèmes c'est-à-dire les
problèmes de justice qui peuvent rendre
plusieurs années moi je dis réglons le
problème arrêtons de nous cacher
derrière des fausses en moyenne
tellement de gens qui souffrent c'est
tellement un moteur pour pour la haine
du politique pour je dirais la tristesse
des gens qui qui vous appellent qui
perdent leurs miens à un moment donné on
a un esprit enfin un devoir de
responsabilité moi j'avais besoin
d'explication j'ai dû rater un épisode
il me semblait que tout ça avait été
réglé par la loi Maryvonne de 2015 vous
savez Maryvonne c'était une autogénaire
rennaise qui s'était qui qui avait qui
possédait une maison qui était squattée
et elle ne pouvait plus
faire sortir les squatteurs il y avait
tout le monde s'était ému de cette
histoire la maison avait été très
fortement dégradée et finalement il y a
une noix en 2015 qui a été adoptée pour
dire que finalement on pouvait
intervenir la police pouvait intervenir
au-delà du délai de 48 heures
aujourd'hui on voit que le sujet revient
sur la table pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que pourquoi est-ce qu'à chaque fois le
problème se repose parce qu'on refuse de
parler du problème de fond moi j'ai
commencé à travailler avant Maryvonne le
fait de en 2015 je leur ai dit ça ne va
pas régler le problème c'est exact ça
n'a rien réglé c'est exactement un petit
peu c'est exactement la même philosophie
que l'amendement qui est proposé
actuellement c'est de dire on va
protéger
la résidence principale et la résidence
éventuellement secondaire et résidence
occasionnelle donc en fonction de la
notion de domicile on reste toujours
dans la protection de la vie privée et
lorsqu'il y a un squat c'est à dire donc
quelque part une infraction moralité
vous aurez toujours des trous dans la
raquette demain vous achetez un
appartement vous faites de la rénovation
ça n'est pas encore votre résidence
principale quelqu'un vient la squatter
vous n'êtes pas protégé par cet
amendement vous aviez acheté un petit
logement pour votre retraite vous le
louiez à un moment donné il est squatté
ça n'est pas votre résidence principale
le secondaire quelqu'un vient
s'installer dans votre garage ça n'est
pas votre résidence principale donc vous
buterez toujours sur des problèmes du
jurisprudence et d'interprétation la loi
et toujours c'est toujours le cas de la
police si vous voulez on dit on va agir
au moment si vous voulez du flagrant
délit or tous les cas ne sont pas des
flagrants daily moi j'ai une dame qui
est venue me voir pas plus tard qu'il y
a trois jours locataire indélicat il
fait ses premiers mois puis au bout d'un
an au bout de deux mois il arrête de
payer
vous avez les mêmes problèmes donc à mon
avis il faut protéger la proprio et
c'est pas un problème de logement c'est
un problème d'impunité pénal et c'est
pas chez même wargon c'est Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti qui se tait depuis 15
jours sur le sujet allez on va parler de
votre partie Julia Robert les
républicains Xavier Bertrand qui fait
donc un pas de plus un grand pas vers sa
candidature à la présidentielle ce
serait le pont le bon candidat pour
votre camp il ferait un bon candidat
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui je partage
notamment sa volonté de renouer le fil
avec les classes populaires avec les ces
électorat populaire qui était celui du
RP qui nous a quittés parce qu'il dit
finalement vous ne nous avait pas
protégé et vous ne comprenez pas après
il a une fibre plus nordiste
c'est-à-dire une question sociale dans
le sud il y a aussi un malaise
identitaire et culturelle le fameux
séparatisme personne ne veut le voir
mais voilà ça pose un vrai problème que
dans les rues de certaines villes du sud
vous ayez des gens qui s'habillent comme
un Arabie Saoudite voilà puis après on
s'étonne qu'à Strasbourg vous ayez une
femme qui se fasse violenter parce
qu'elle portait une jupe et parce qu'on
dit mais si tu portes une jupe tu es une
femme de mauvaise vie je ne dis pas le
terme qui a été utilisé mais c'est ça le
fond du problème bon et puis il y a un
malaise économique global sur lequel est
un déclassement il peut rassembler votre
camp Xavier Bertrand vous savez c'est
une question qui est difficile à je
dirais résoudre d'abord parce
qu'aujourd'hui hier on en parlait pas
aujourd'hui tout le monde en parle vous
avez plusieurs autres candidats vous
avez Bruno retaillod qui s'est déclaré
vous avez sans doute Valérie Pécresse
moi je pense si vous voulez qu'on doit
d'abord établir des règles pour moi
aussi je suis candidat
il faut savoir rester à sa place mais
vous avez plein d'autres qui
s'intéressent oui mais c'est pour être
candidat c'est pas très compliqué
et beaucoup de courage ou beaucoup d'ego
et peu de courage il est plus dans votre
liste François Barran vous n'y croyez
plus à sa candidature
moi j'ai cru comprendre si vous voulez
que il avait pas envie d'être candidats
mais je crois qu'il faut établir des
règles d'abord pour voir comment est-ce
qu'on le comment est-ce qu'on soutient
voilà comment on détermine le soutien et
puis ensuite il y a un débat sur le fond
on a trop tendance à critiquer les
personnes ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
sujet de la souveraineté moi je verrai
chez les candidats lequel a compris le
plus sensiblement qu'on ne peut pas
mettre en place n'importe quelle
politique si on ne rétablit pas les
outils de la souveraineté sur ce
territoire ce qui ne veut pas dire être
nationaliste anti-européen autarcique
comme on le fait croire voilà mais par
exemple la justice a pris beaucoup trop
d'indépendance le politique peut voter
des lois si demain les juges font ce
qu'ils veulent et bien vous ne servez à
rien et les gens vous disent pourquoi il
reste voté c'est aussi simple que ça
Gérard Larcher président du Sénat ne
cesse de parler d'un processus de
départage à construire pour pour
départager les candidats et les
candidats de la droite et du centre
c'était des questions présidentielle ça
pourrait être pour vous ce serait ça
pourrait être quoi ce fameux processus
de départage entendu personne n'a envie
chez les républicains de revivre une
primaire si j'ai bien compris non mais
le mot de primaire personne n'a envie de
revivre l'affaire Fillon personne n'a
envie de revivre une primaire ouverte ou
des socialistes sont venus voter pour
choisir notre candidat du coup qu'est-ce
qui reste ce qui reste à mon avis c'est
un processus de départage ou les
adhérents qui vont vivre les
républicains ont quand même un poids
substantiel majoritaire dans le collège
électoral vous pouvez pas dire à des
gens qui font vos campagnes qui font
vivre votre partie toute l'année au
moment de choisir de la grande échéance
votre avis ne compte pas je défends la
souveraineté le citoyen français a plus
de droits que celui qui vient d'arriver
qui est de l'autre côté de la frontière
et bien ça vaut pour les républicains
celui qui était là avant et qui fait
vivre ce parti à plus de droits que
celui qui passe le bureau et qui dit
coucou je viens choisir votre candidat
donc un choix réservé aux seuls
militants non pas forcément parce que on
peut élargir à condition que le socle
des gens qui sont adhérents garde une
majorité par exemple associer des
parties qui soutiennent des candidats
vous avez Bertrand veut participer la
manufacture on pourrait avoir un autre
système qui passe par un collège élector
à la doc avec des conseillers nationaux
élus par les adhérents et puis pourquoi
pas les mères les conseillers
départementaux conseiller régionaux en
Carter ce qui permettrait peut-être
d'équilibrer et d'avoir une
représentation de toute la diversité
territoriale un président de Région un
grand impact sur les maires de sa propre
région donc oui on peut trouver la
question pour plus on peut si vous
voulez qu'on reste entre gens
raisonnable voilà sinon bah écoutez on
ira pas de positionner des partages et
ça se réglera cette égo liste au premier
tour la question est de savoir si ça
nous aura préjudiciable ou pas faut que
ça soit tranché quand pour vous ah c'est
une question qu'il faut poser au
président du parti j'ai compris qu'il
voulait remettre après les régionales la
question du mode de désignation mais qui
voulait y répondre moi j'ai plaidé pour
que on discute avant les régionales la
mode de départage quand on ne connaît
pas encore les candidats parce que quand
vous connaissez les candidats ça vient
évidemment coloré ça peut colorer les
règles puisque quelqu'un qui sait qui va
être candidat va dire mais moi je
préfère tel système parce que je ça
m'est évidemment
l'idée d'un candidat ou d'une candidate
providentielle quelqu'un suffisamment
charismatique qui s'imposerait
naturellement à tous ça c'est vous y
croyez ou c'est ça pourrait être qui ça
peut arriver peut-être que Nicolas
Sarkozy voudrait un jour partir vous
savez encore un soir
j'y crois j'en sais rien pour tout vous
dire
moi je souhaite que on est un candidat
qui tire les leçons de nos erreurs du
passé c'est très compliqué aussi pour
voilà quand on a été aux affaires c'est
très compliqué c'est plus compliqué de
le faire et qu'il soit capable de réunir
la droite et surtout de parler à ces
gens qui nous ont quitté et qui sont
nombreux un dernier mot sur l'écologie
puisque vous vous intéressez à ces
questions et Aurélien Pradier qui entame
un tour de France environnemental est-ce
que les LR ont mis trop de temps à
s'intéresser à ces questions est-ce que
du coup ils ne sont pas en retard en
tout cas je ne sais pas moi non ça fait
8 ans que je travaille dessus et l'an
dernier sorti un livret vert on dit que
la droite ne réfléchit pas c'est faux
avec quelques parlementaires membres
d'oser la France mon mouvement nous
avons sorti vous en pensez quoi
peut-être qu'il va trouver quelque chose
d'internative mais vous savez au bout de
8 ans j'en suis quand même arrivé à à
considérer que voir les points de
convergence et de divergence parce que
sur le diagnostic c'est assez clair vous
savez sur l'énergie ça fait longtemps
que on plaide au Parlement
pour une politique qui se différente de
celle du gouvernement mais en tout cas
je ne peux faire que la publicité du
livre d'oser la France et qui s'appelle
livret vert pour une écologie humaniste
la différence si vous voulez c'est que
moi je ne défends pas une écologie de
droite je crois que c'est pas de droite
ou de gauche je pense qu'il y a une
écologie radicale qui élimine l'homme
des processus de décision et des
processus d'application de cette
écologie et moi je défends une écologie
dans ton peu débattre rationnel et qui
effectivement respecte aussi les
traditions et les coutumes de nos
territoires et merci